thanks everyone for coming to this I
know it's a little difficult waking up
from the food coma after lunch I was
nervous about this slot so I'll try to
keep it interesting for all of you so
you don't fall asleep and if you do
don't be too obvious about it okay so
I'm Daniella I am working in engineering
at a start-up in San Francisco called
light stuff we sell monitoring software
to other software companies and our
platform is primarily based on
distributed tracing hence the topic that
I wanted to talk to all of you about
today focus on the insights that we can
derive from trace aggregates so I don't
know the background for all of you in
the audience I'm gonna quickly go
through a few slides on the basics of
tracing given that it's a I think a
quickly growing concept I'm not going to
spend too much time on the basics and
then move quickly into the theme for
today which is trace aggregates so
pictured here is our CEO Ben Siegelman
he was the first person I think to come
up with this terminology that I want to
share with all of you today called the
pipes of observability you might have
heard a different term called the three
pillars of observability people call
them metrics logs and traces the subtle
difference here that I really want to
share because I agree a lot with it is
pillars sort of suggest that if you have
either one of metrics logs or traces
you're done you you're good to go with
your system after you you are able to
derive those metrics or logs or traces
from your system and that's false
because they're just data like there's
no value in raw data the value really
comes from what insight or what analysis
we can present to developers so they
understand the root cause or what's
going on in their system so the
difference here is that they're really
you think of them as transportation for
carrying the raw data to you and then
there's a step missing which is the
insight and the analysis which sometimes
humans do that manually here I'm gonna
present a bunch of analysis and I'm
hoping machines can do for us because
they
sleeeeep okay so moving on another quick
review there's a lot of talk about
tracing today so it's as we want to
quickly go through the value proposition
you've probably heard this elsewhere so
just bear with me for those of you that
are familiar with this concept which is
traditional systems live on the same
server or the same set of servers and to
scale we just beefed it up we add more
CPU memory network whatsoever and it's
all kept together in a monolith in one
system and the traditional monitoring
tools give you log lines metrics counts
through that kind of window into
observing into your system but another
book buzzword I have up there
micro-services break this paradigm
because for any given request we now
have hundreds of thousands of smaller
services serving a very small particular
part of the functionality of your total
system and then you have this broken red
line on the right where it might travel
through a bunch of services and if you
still use traditional monitoring tools
you're gonna get a lot from server a a
lot from server B and you still have to
thread either the locks or metrics
together in order to tell the story and
a lot of the time it still happens
manually whether it's your own call
engineer or maybe a DevOps team so the
value proposition of distributive
tracing is that a trace is the only
piece of raw data that tells a story
that's end to end in a distributed
multi-tiered system because it follows
the requests that follows through
request the life of the request okay
so moving on this is pretty crucial so
again people probably have seen this
before I just want to make sure we're on
the same page visually in a lot of
monitoring tools any tools you find out
there if you google tracing will show a
trace in a waterfall layout like this so
you have your top what we call a root
span each of these operations each of
these rows we call a span which is just
the unit of work representing a part of
a trace so the root span the yellow one
at the top is the one that you care
about the transaction that you're either
trying to optimize or the one that you
know serves your website or something
that that you want to monitor and that
calls out to different services each one
I've highlighted in a separate color
another web framework several our pcs
maybe an even external call that you
have to navigate some kind of network
call and then they might call out to
other API so so then you get this nice
waterfall and then as you move from left
to right obviously the the length of the
span itself represents the time that was
spent in that operation so that's pretty
pretty clear to everybody let's zoom out
a little bit and look at a single trace
without all the details you essentially
if you squint a little bit see this
waterfall view everywhere if you look at
a second trace for the same transaction
has the same shape some operations might
have taken longer and shorter so but
generally has the same shape now the
problem with tracing well not a problem
but one downside you can't have
everything is that there's hundreds of
thousands of transactions in a
production system and and it's likely
not feasible at all to capture all of
them and frankly you don't want to
capture all of them because you don't
want to pay to capture uninteresting
transactions 99% of the transactions you
probably don't even care about so for
tracing to be cost effective it almost
always involves sampling now you can be
intelligent about the sampling deciding
where to keep what traces to keep for
the most part a lot of tracing systems
the basic ones just do ingress sampling
meaning that you flip a coin or roll a
die and you keep the transaction or not
so you have a set of traces and in a lot
of the tools you will look at this
tracing view and this is what you see
and maybe you open it in five tabs so
you can look at like five different
traces and try to try to find a pattern
among them now the problem here is of
course that humans have limited capacity
to analyze large amounts of data so no
matter how many Chrome browser tabs you
open you probably crash your chrome
before you're able to actually root
cause and feel confident that you've
looked at enough traces to note that the
problem is caused by that exact one
thing if you're lucky you might get a
trace that tells you exactly what's
wrong but you don't know if the trace is
representative you don't know if you've
captured an uninteresting trace versus
the one that's copying your incident
so of course this is the meet of my talk
today which is what happens when we
gather hundreds or thousands of traces
and we feed it to a machine we do all
kinds of analysis and let the Machine
surface interesting insights to us so we
don't have to do the manual analysis
ourselves so there's three I'm not going
to read through them all I did want to
highlight the last one because that's
what my demo is gonna be on also the
first two have been more or less vetted
by the industry and are in a lot of
production system being used already the
third one is why I'm here today which is
to explore this concept of using it for
a different kind of analysis but I will
go through the first two first okay so
starting with this concept of
correlation based on statistical
analysis there's a lot of kind of fancy
words there I will go through what I
mean so this is a real incident that
light stuff suffered
I think someone got paged and then we
were looking at what happened a couple
of days later to do a post-mortem on it
and this was the dashboard that they saw
at the time so this is our internal
dashboard it's the first one that we go
to clearly something went wrong around I
think for those of you that can't see at
the back it says very small but it's
around twelve o'clock on Monday the 22nd
there's a big spike in everything
problem one when the on-call engineer
came here other than knowing that
something was wrong because they got
paged and that things are actually wrong
in the system very difficult to know
which graph to dig into first because
they're all correlated with each other
you don't know which one is just the
symptom of the problem and which one is
actually the problem itself I'm gonna
skip all the investigation as good right
to the end the root cause was that we
had a customer that was inadvertently
ddossing our entire ingestion system you
know we should have had better
protection against that whatever but
that's a separate talk that's we we we
brought our essentially they
accidentally brought our ingestion
system down and then I have to
manufacture this graph which didn't
exist on the dashboard just to show that
if you knew two segments by the customer
ID which we did have
some of the operations and then I had to
filter it down to all the different
projects that the customer had so I
think they have maybe like six here you
could see that there was one project
that was like obviously completely out
of whack we didn't have this graph that
now the problem is I skipped that
investigation it took a few hours to
actually get to the root cause and then
contact them so they could you know turn
down they had a faulty token so they
were ddosing us because they had a
really aggressive retry system anyway it
took hours and it just took way too long
to get to such a simple root cause
because we didn't know that we had to
segment by customer ID that is not
something we have by default on our
default dashboard page and the reason
why we don't have it is because we don't
have that tag because the cardinality
the number of unique values is too high
you can easily have hundreds and
thousands of customers hundreds of
thousands of customers if you're like an
Amazon and it's just an expense it's
really expensive and infeasible to have
these kinds of dashboards we didn't have
prior knowledge that we had to segment
it by customers and really even if we
did and we could graph it it kind of
looks like this
I was most likely just look like noise
because the real signal gets drowned out
by the noise so that's sort of what I
want to convince you all that is not
efficient to do this kind of analysis
with high cardinality values
characteristics in your system using
just metrics alone so then I want to
present how we can do this using tracing
instead so I've made this very pretty
graph in excel with my front-end skills
so the idea here is to use a different
kind of analysis here I have a latency
histogram for those of you that's not
familiar with it because I wasn't
familiar with it we essentially create
these arbitrary buckets for a latency so
at the very left you have 0 to 50 at the
very right it's between 950 and a
thousand and with some unit let's say
milliseconds I actually put it up there
ok good for me so what we do is let's
say there's a thousand traces we've
collected for a given transaction
and we basically plot the count for each
bucket so if you have a transaction
that's 40 milliseconds we would
increment the count of the leftmost
bucket by one and we do this for all
1,000 of them and we have this pretty
latency histogram that represents all
the latencies in your system for a given
number of traces I'm using a thousand so
that the math is easier it's obviously
not that nice and real out in reality
and then I've drawn a line for the p99
just to show you like I mean this is
literally how the percentiles are
calculated is how to the right of the
p99 line we have the three buckets that
contain the top 1% slowest transactions
and then you can see that as you move
from left to right the transactions get
slower ok so what can we do now that
we've plotted this so remember that
trace the waterfall view and then you
have spans so trace is a context rich
primitive meaning that at the time of
instrumentation at the time when you
generate the trace you can attach tags
and these are not limited in cardinality
you can you can attach tags that have a
lot of hundreds of thousand millions of
unique values if you will so one of the
tags we can attach to this trace is
which customer made this request and we
have these tags on all of our traces and
then given that we have a bunch of
traces and you can look at now you can
run the statistical analysis very simple
it's basically a correlation coefficient
so you look at the slowest top view top
1% slowest requests and you say what are
the defining characteristics what's hot
what's similar about these requests
compared to the rest of the 99% and then
you can plot it again so here I've
overlaid a certain tag so in this case
it was the problematic customer and you
can see there's a pretty strong
correlation between requests that
contain that customer ID and slowness at
the request and you can do this not just
for this tag but for any tag that has a
high correlation coefficient and it
immediately reduces the investigation
time from hours to minutes it doesn't
solve the problem it's still a
correlation not a causation but it is a
very strong hypothesis for the developer
to then
I'll manually go check and look into
whether there's actually something wrong
with this customer or maybe they just
generate requests with a lot of slow
with a lot of our pcs associated with it
maybe they just have giant requests
that's fine
but it's pretty it's a pretty strong
educated guess towards it it's a hint to
two point then uncle engineer if you get
woken up at 3:00 a.m. your brains really
not working that well and this page will
basically tell you hey go look at this
customer see what's wrong with them okay
so we productionize this and it's pretty
cool because that was a theoretical
example this is a real-world example
that happened to you know one of our
initial customers so there was actually
a faulty network card and one of their
data centers it's funny because in this
case it was a it was a physical
infrastructure problem that we debugged
using software and this is the latency
histogram that that they saw and what
happened was I think there was this
server rack I feel like I'm Way out of
my league here and something was wrong
with the rack and any requests that
happened to land on that server which is
timeout so you basically have this long
tail latency you have a cluster of
transactions that for some reason took
almost 100 milliseconds where most of
the transactions usually takes around 10
milliseconds so they're investigating
this they pull up this histogram for all
the traces they have for the transaction
and we draw the P 99.9 so in this case
everything to the right of that line is
in your top slowest 0.1 percent and then
in the black we've essentially overlaid
the correlation the strong correlation
we found which is almost a perfect
correlation between your top slow 0.1%
and the server ID that they that they
have so using this again as a hint so it
still requires somebody I think maybe a
technician to actually go into that data
center and then do a bunch of
inspections to make sure that all the
servers are open running correctly and
find the actual physical infrastructure
issue replace the network card or
whatever and bring the latency back to
normal and this took and and I don't
want to quote them but but essentially
it took a lot less time
and it would have otherwise if ever they
were gonna solve this issue of longtail
latency so I thought it was a pretty
cool example okay
finally I want to now present something
that we haven't productionize and it's
sort of an explorer exploratory research
into a new kind of analysis we can do
and that is on critical path so back to
this trace we can again look at a couple
of them for the same transaction it'll
have a similar shape and the similarity
between all three of these traces is
that redline I've highlighted to sort of
draw everyone's attention to it
that's your critical path we kind of
define it as this the operation that
contributes to your overall transaction
duration in such a way that if you
reduce your critical path you reduce the
overall duration of your transaction so
that is what you want to optimize you
don't want to optimize one of those
little gray bars and actually in reality
that's not easy to immediately figure
out without looking at a trace or a
bunch of logs or metrics to get that
intuition anyway so we've identified the
critical path that's actually the easy
part
rarely will developers be surprised when
you tell them what their critical path
is because they know you know it's
probably some kind of a contention on
the database or some kind of a third
party API call that just usually takes a
really long time so the where is not
surprising and it's valuable but it's
not that valuable but rarely do they
tell you this any kind of analysis tell
you why it's being contended upon
sometimes you know when the system is
small as your system grows
you don't really don't know how the
contention has changed over time so the
why usually lies and this is a
hypothesis again usually lies in the
fact that all latency issues are due to
contention of some sort so contending
upon CPU memory Network a database row
my example today here of picked in
particular is a lock contention a mutex
contention which happens I think a lot
even internally in our system we have
this all the time so in this case I've
put the word mutex acquired to show that
the critical path is you've come up to
this point in your operation you want to
acquire
to do the work it's not available so you
wait for it and that waiting period is
your critical path and then you can see
that little gray bar at the end when you
finally acquire the lock and do a little
bit of work and then release it so
that's what we're gonna look at today
pretend that there's a lock contention
it's some kind of a system really the
analogy that I really like to think
about is understanding why traffic is
jammed so in a traffic jam if you're in
one of those cars at the very end you
want to know what's going on and what's
holding up all that traffic and it's
actually pretty difficult to figure it
out without being there yourself
sometimes there's like various stupid
reasons and maybe you could have gone
around the whole traffic thing maybe
everybody is trying to take one exit and
you don't want to go to that exit but
you're not sure cuz might miss out on
the exit so essentially if you knew what
was going on you can make a more
intelligent decision about where to go
next on how to optimize your journey and
that's exactly what we're trying to do
here we're trying to figure out what's
going on with the lock so that we can
figure out how to optimize it further so
we're not doing work and taking steps in
the dark hoping that it will help with
the situation so thankfully with that
analogy we can use trace aggregate
analysis again to sort of stick with the
theme of today's talk how we do that is
I basically overlaid a bunch of traces
here to illustrate what this analysis is
doing I've removed however all the other
spans except for the critical path so at
the bottom with all the colorful bars
those are all the critical paths of all
the different traces that you've
collected and you know they're various
lengths but they're they're always the
critical path of their particular trace
and what you can do with this remember
there's this concept of tagging each of
your trace you can tag your trace with
the lock that is trying to that is being
acquired right so you can uniquely
identify each of your lock in your
system by just an ID and then you can
figure out you can gather the critical
path group it by the lock ID so you're
studying a particular lock and this in
this example you're studying some lock
ID mutex F 7 8 whatever and then you can
look at all the colors remember in the
traces context rich so you can actually
back trace and back propagate and figure
out who's actually trying to call to
acquire this lock and then you can
aggregate
callers then all of a sudden if we
present it nicely and visually you get a
very clear picture of what's contending
for resources in your lock and which
resources are contended by which callers
upstream right and this could be several
layers up so you can go as far up as you
want in order to get that kind of
insight so this is what I'm gonna try to
do in my example today before I go into
the demo I did want to cover two very
simple terminologies because I'm gonna
use it later is this concept of having
waiter so these are the process the
threads or whatever in my case it's
essentially different like orders you're
gonna see what I mean
and they're called waiters when they're
waiting on a given lock and then after
they acquire the lock they become
holders they hold on to the lock do the
work release it for the next person so
the architecture that I've said with
today it's you know a little fun startup
that I have donut as a service
move fast and bake things so it's a
really simple web app I wrote and go
it has a donut client that orders Donuts
on a background it generates all these
orders for different flavors of donut
and then I have a donut server that
serves these orders sends them to the
payment service make sure that they're
paying me for my service and then go
through the fryer service in the topper
service both of these are serial so you
can only fry one donut at a time so you
must acquire the fryer lock before you
can fry your donut and then move on to
the topper service you must get the
topper lock and then sprinkle your donut
before giving it to the next donut to be
sprinkled or sorry to be topped and then
in my example what I've also done is I
have a little donut generator running to
order these donuts I've basically varied
the rate of the amount of orders that's
been coming in that'll be really obvious
when I do my demo later so you don't
have an equal amount of sprinkles donas
versus chocolate versus cinnamon okay
so I've tried to procrastinate this but
here we go so well I've done is I will
switch to my handy terminal window and
start my generator so I have the program
running in the in the background
and then maximize this and go to my
program
there we go so I have a little demo
project set up to receive their traces
from the donut application that's
running and then I'm gonna go find one
of the trace just to show you what I
mean
sorry it's a little slow the computer is
running pretty hot and I'm gonna go to
the donut web server this is a little
search interface like I can find traces
easily and then I'm going to go to my
background order which I talked about
and then I'm gonna run my query give it
a second to gather all the information
by the way you can see this histogram
it's literally the screenshot I took
earlier okay so we have a list you can
see they're all taking like various
number of seconds I'm just gonna open
and random one in a different tab to
show you this trace it's the same trace
of that architecture but represented in
that waterfall format that all of you
now are so familiar with let it gather
assemble cool so as you can see it
because we don't know how long the
transaction is if it's done or not we're
just waiting for it to finish assembling
but it's pretty much done as you can see
this is your root span the the
background order
I've actually tagged it with a flavor
cinnamon and then it goes into making
the donut we can collapse it just to
focus one span at a time to make donut
operation then has three sub operations
process payment fry and then top so if
we open fry we can see that there's a
fryer fried donut operation again you
can see that cinnamon the tag sort of
threaded through and then it goes into
mutex acquire so this is your critical
path in our UI we actually highlight it
in yellow to show you that this is the
critical path that is waiting for the
fryer lock and then if you come down
here to mutex hold you can see that I've
tagged it with fryer lock so that later
on I can when I do my analysis I know
what you lock I'm looking at fryer
versus topper in your real system
obviously you're gonna have way more
locks than two and then the exact same
setup on the sprinkle side you have
flavor tagged and then if you look at
the lock you can see that it has a
different name called topper lock so
this is the trace essentially as
expected and then what I basically have
here is let me maximize this I have
added this little analysis that now I
run on the back end now I am essentially
a back-end engineer so this is the
previous visualization I could come up
with on the front end but you can
imagine the possibilities here but I saw
I did I did a little you know graph I
picked out the two locks the top is
let's say it's a sprinkle here so the
top is the topper lock or the the lock
you have to acquire to put your topping
on the bottom is the fryer lock the
difference in them isn't that
interesting so I'm just gonna focus on
the top one and over here what you have
is the wait waiting time right so if you
look at the waiting time the the dark
brown is sprinkles oh sorry it's
chocolate of course
dark brown yeah I did that the the
reddish one is cinnamon and then the
green one is sprinkles so the the
different color bars show you the
different flavors on how long an order
for that donut has spent hold in total
time right so this is like total
whatever wall clock time that they spent
waiting for that lock to be available
and you can see that like cinnamon just
towers over everything else which makes
sense because when I generate at my
background order that's the sort of the
rate that I turned up the rate for a
cinnamon waiting time is actually on
average pretty fair so you can see that
you know the whatever the go lock
library works so that's good it's
essentially a random selection now on
the holders it's pretty interesting now
because you can see it takes so much
longer to apply topping for a chocolate
doughnut and that's again sort of by
design I put in a little a timer for how
long each top topping takes and
chocolate does take a longer but you
know if I hadn't if that was the real
system then I don't know that and but
it's very obvious right if you look at
these two graphs to actually gather this
data one by one and look at a trace
maybe you would have gathered that like
if you look at enough traces with a
chocolate or
versus the cinnamon order you figure out
like hey it's holding on to the lock a
lot more but I just think that it's very
difficult to say with how much
confidence that happens and this
basically gives you that data you can
show somebody this and say look
chocolate hold on to the lock for way
longer and a simple a simple solve in
this case what we would do is break out
the lock like chocolate can have its own
lock it can hold on to the lock for as
long as it wants it'll still impact
other chocolate orders but you know
that's sort of a bigger architecture
redesign and then cinnamon and sprinkles
cuz she still share the same lock and
you know what it'll make your cinnamon
order so much faster and increase the
throughput of your system and you know
whatever make more money maybe we can
raise a different round of funding with
with this kind of analysis so I don't
know I I thought when I did this
exercise was pretty cool um so back to
my presentation because I want to
respect the next
ah there we go oh that worked look uh
and I don't need my backup slides cool
so I just you know just in case it
always happens thank you yeah I very
strong believer in Murphy's Law by the
way I even have a video on my on my
desktop it's like everything else fails
in the slides like disappear or
something which had almost did okay so
what was this talk about I need to wrap
up now so that the next speaker has time
and hopefully we have time for some
questions this talk was about a list of
things I said a lot of words and I
usually get a lot of advice for public
speaking from people who are much better
at it than me and I've heard this advice
many times which is that you always talk
about what you will talk about at the
beginning of your talk and then you
repeat what you talked about at the end
of your talk I'm not gonna do that today
I don't I don't want to do it because I
just I never remember these things when
I'm sort of an audience so I just want
you to remember that trace aggregates is
what you want not just the single trace
you're not done if like a fellow
developer comes to you and says like
look at this trace and you're gonna be
like okay where where is your analysis
where is your aggregate analysis because
I believe that the time of getting a
single trace is over like you know maybe
five six years ago when tracing was
still a pretty new concept it's exciting
to see a trace but it's only one
transaction out of millions and it's not
representative and it's it's just hard
to really do anything with a trace so
please remember trace aggregates just
those two words I feel like everybody
can do that
and then before I end just a quick plug
for open telemetry which is something
that our company contributes a lot to
I'm really excited about it it's
essentially in the next major version if
you if you've heard about open tracing
and open census it is the open source
standard for telemetry data logs metrics
tracing primarily I think I'm you know
I'm obviously we work with the tracing
aspect of it a lot more in order to get
any kind of insight you need at least I
think thousands of traces so in order to
get aggregates you need a lot traces in
order to have a lot of traces you need
to figure out how to get those out of
your system instrument a
integration with existing libraries that
have them and you probably don't want to
be locked into a given vendor so
open-source is good that's why I'm
excited about it and it's also super
exciting that this is potentially sort
of the native built-in feature for any
cloud native integration or cloud native
software so you know if you use urban
Nettie's if you have a service mesh and
you use sto it's you know it'll it'll
eventually be built in that's super cool
and you get you get telemetry data for
free I mean quotes um cool I think I
stuck to my timeline um thank you very
much for listening
I should have questions that will just
double check the time five minutes for
questions perfect do we have any yes sir
yeah repeating the question with open to
elementary or any of the open tracing
open census how do you know how to put
useful traces in a really good question
you're the developer if your so there's
two ways right there's manual
instrumentation there's automatic
integration which I kind of alluded to a
little bit if you're using a third-party
library that's really popular I
mentioned SEO for service mesh they
already have that built in and all you
have to do is sort of configure like a
few lines of configuration to tell them
where to send your traces and voila you
have everything if you want more
in-depth instrumentation of your actual
application logic then you're the one
that wrote the program you're the one
that um should know which pieces are
more interesting there's a lot of best
practice blog posts videos talks on how
to construct your trace and how to
optimize sending traces so that you're
not you're not bombarding your you're
tracing vendor with with too much done
uninteresting traffic so that's that's
how you would have to learn to figure
that figure that on your system and
again there's best practices around like
which functions like you don't want to
trace per for loop for example per
iteration of your for loop so these
these things the the literature is out
there
anything else if you'll free I'm gonna
stick around probably around this area
if you want to come up and chat about
other things if you don't feel
comfortable asking a question in public
or it's too in-depth for a public forum
otherwise I'm gonna let the next speaker
have time to setup awesome thank you
[Applause]